here's a parent
i don't know if i'll play this the whole
thing here but he's speaking out against
crt this is a black parrot we'll mention
and at his school board and here's what
he has to say about critical race 3
let's play it
the non-discrimination resolution the
crt deal
because it's it's happening and as a
parent i speak to other parents there's
a few things that we don't want
i'm bi-racial i'm bilingual i'm
multicultural the fact is in america in
north carolina i can do anything i want
and i teach that to my children and the
person who tells my little pecan colored
kids that they're somehow oppressed
based on the color of their skin would
be absolutely wrong and absolutely at
war with me
and i think that's the same for every
parent with the mask showed us is that
the parents the most powerful group of
people in our country that they're
taking back the wheel
now obviously we had to take the wheel
back for the mask but we're taking the
wheel back from washington all the way
to raleigh and into our local school
board
because crt
all of that the parents don't want it
it's a big fat lie there's not one if
they're if you believe in crt i want to
tell you you're a liar because that
means you look at your black neighbor
and say that they're oppressed and you
look at your white neighbor and say that
they're evil regardless of the
experience that you've had with them
and we're not going to do that the
parents in the united states of america
right here in north carolina and
cabarrus county we know that's not true
because we believe the lives we live the
fact is i've been a business owner right
here in north carolina and i deal with
white people black people hispanic
people my children deal with everybody
and the racism is only happening at the
government level and on the media the
fact is you have races and there's like
you can't even find them hardly you just
hear the stories about them
but this is this is what we're dealing
with
the parents are taking the wheel i have
an eight-year-old daughter who is
absolutely dynamic
it's an important perspective
too because we talk about critical race
theory and uh you know i've pointed out
that it's
anti-white racism
which it is and we have to call it that
and we have to condemn anti-white races
because it's a
it's it's the only acceptable form of
racism
left in america which means that it's it
deserves most of our attention
um the types of racism that almost
everyone agrees are bad well we don't
have to talk about it much because
everyone agrees it's bad
but his perspective is also important
too because because
it's quite
demoralizing
to say the least
when you tell someone
tell a kid from a very young age that
he's a press and he's a victim and
you're and you're driving that into his
head
now it's also bad when you tell a kid
that because of his skin color he's a
villain and he has something to
apologize for and should feel guilty
but honestly if i had if if i could
choose
you know if we were if we were actually
able to identify as whatever race and uh
decide which benefits we want to enjoy
i i think i would i would still prefer
to be shouted out shouted down as the
villain
and be blamed for all of the
world's atrocities
and every bad thing that's ever happened
in history
i think i would prefer that
over constantly being told that i'm a
victim and i'm oppressed and there's
nothing i can do about it
i'd prefer neither of those options but
if i had to choose one
i think i'd rather be called the villain
than be called the helpless victim
because when you're the helpless victim
you have your free wills being taken
away
you know you're immediately being
assigned this position
and
so it's quite degrading and dehumanizing
so we appreciate that
from that parent
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated